love to leave you with a little
something to go and we like to call it
the doggy bag
there it goes and today we're talking
about a product that i am a huge fan of
and i hope you guys are going to love it
what
uh
oh
[Applause]
i'm so happy to see you well i heard you
were shooting on the lot you know i've
been here so long i'm like the welcome
wagon so i brought you
a welcome
basket
and you know your grandfather shot a lot
of movies here right
so i found some photos of him on the lot
here
so how about that that is
that is so sweet
you know i i knew that he was here but i
i didn't have any photographic evidence
of it yeah well there you go and i've
got something even more special for you
this is amazing
you know he shot one of the most iconic
movies ever
this
is the original
poster
for dr jekyll and mr hyde from the 20s
i
am um
i'm going to put these up immediately i
love that you're going to be associated
with these
moments because you're bringing me
closer to my roots you're welcome and
thank you for being my friend and
welcome to the paramount lot do not park
in my spot
i will let you finish your show and do
what you do
well
thank you ross thank you dr phil
house calls with dr phil actually airs
wednesdays at 9pm on cbs and season 20
of dr phil airs weekdays and you check
your local listings for that i want to
thank all of our guests
and i feel so lucky
and i just
i love you guys
thank you for everyone watching it
or on the go
thank you thank you thank you
[Music]
you